♪♫♪ [In sottofondo, il motivetto jazz che funge da sigla alla serie "Late Show con Karim Musa"] ♪♫♪
Benvenuti ad un nuovo episodio del 'Late show con Karim Musa'
Dunque, io ero pronto, ero pronto per girare
il nuovo episodio di PAUSA; era il pausa
sulla prima puntata di Dragon Ball e avevo anche finito di
scriverlo, mi stavo vestendo, mi stavo mettendo la giacca, la nuova
cravatta ed ero pronto per girare, finchè ad un certo punto
mi arriva una mail di una persona che mi chiede di collaborare
ehhh
ok
ero a casa che guardando Tira & Molla
in TV e di punto in bianco parto
vado alla stazione di Torino Porta Nuova
Mi viene anche una puntina di fame e mi fermo a mangiare qualcosa
e all'improvviso mi ritrovo a Novara
perché come sapete il mio ufficio non può contenere
più di una persona a meno che tu non voglia morire soffocato
e quindi ho avuto una botta di fortuna quando lui mi ha invitato
nel suo ufficio a Novara appunto dove ci sono molte
molte, MOLTE cose fighe
ah vi avverto subito che ci saranno un pochino di problemi tecnici legati all'audio
perchè purtroppo i mezzi che ho sono quelli che vanno bene giusto
per avere una persona davanti alla telecamera che fa video
scemi su internet. Detto questo
è con grande privilegio che vi presento il
primo ospite ufficiale
del Late Show con Karim Musa
Giorgio Vanni
(Giorgio canta la sigla di dragon ball)
...il drago delle sette sfere
Dragon Ball
però nessuno
sa dove....
- Giorgio!
perchè sono.... perchè mi hai chiamato qua oggi
Dove sta!
Ho visto la tua puntata
Intanto ti guardo spesso.
- Grazie mille: ci credo pochissimo ma
No, non è vero: invece ti guardo. Ho visto la tua puntata
Dove commenti la puntata
In cui commenti la prima dei pokemon.Hai presente?
(Canta) Viva i pokemon...
- Si,si, ho presente...
Posa la chitarra per l'amor di Dio.
L'ho presa alta.
- Ho visto.
è da tantissimo tempo che non riguardo la prima puntata
di Dragon Ball.
- Tra l'altro.
Aveva ancora la coda Goku.
Quando ancora aveva la coda.
Ma che bravo, bravissimo. Io ti devo chiedere una cosa
perchè tu hai detto che hai un figlio di 12 anni.
- Si.
- Quindi tu ne hai...?
Allora io ne ho 35
però al contrario, cioè tu sposti
il 5...no ne ho 53.
A parte che complimenti.
- Grazie, grazie.
- Anche tu.
- Si io ne ho 68.
Allora io guarderei la puntata, tanto, voglio dire
"Avviene in un periodo di tempo misterioso...
in un'era sconosciuta di cui nessuno ha mai sentito parlare"
"Oltre un'imponente catena montuosa...
-Eh gli occhiali da cinquantatreenne
-Eccolo!
Va che bello! In silhouette tra l'altro
"Un ragazzino...
- Ci ho provato a fare quel calcio lì...
- A fare anche con le dita così?
- E però mi sono incastrato la gamba
- ahahaha
"Goku conosce Bulma"
(Karim) - Didascalico come titolo
- All'inizio...  io all'inizio pensavo che le sfere fossero delle arance...
con un... e sì perché
- ahahahah
- Le Arance del Drago sarebbe stato un bel (titolo)
- Le Arance del Drago
- Orange ball!
- La vitamina C del drago
E' una storia che è stata ispirata da una... mmmh... dalla mitologia
cinese, lo scimmione
- Sì il Son Goku
- Ecco infatti
- Sì Sì
- E questo mi ha sempre affascinato molto
-BANZAIII!!!
- ahahahah
- E questa roba qua la fa anche un mio amico
- Era già doppiata dalla Signorina Pacotto Bulma?
- Mi sembra di sì... sì sì adesso... ero meno attento...
- Sì è lei! Assolutamente Emanuela.
- Sì Sì
- Ciao Emanuela
- Molto forte, che doppia anche
il team Rocket, un personaggio del team rocket
- aaah
Jessie (fuori campo)
- Jessie
- Jessie, giusto assolutamente
Beh James era difficile... che fosse doppiato dalla Pacotto
- Intanto c'è del nudo integrale
- Lui fa la pipì
- C'ha la coda e fa la pipì
- Del nudo integrale sulla Mediaset per bambini
???
- Non ho capito cos'abbia detto    - Plata potata oggi, credo che abbia detto quello
(Giorgio) - è ottimo per una sigla "plata potata oggi"
- Io e Max Longhi, con cui faccio tutte le sigle... Ciao Max
Ci sta guardando assolutamente
Io lo chiamo "l'ammiraglio Max", la ciurma mi chiama "Capitano" e io lo chiamo "ammiraglio Max"
- Che bel luogo di lavoro
- Mi ricordo che non vedevamo i primi cartoni, questo è stato uno dei primi che abbiamo fatto
per il quale abbiam fatto la sigla, non ci davano ancora il dvd
(Karim) - Ok
(Giorgio) - Perché probabilmente non si fidavano
- No giustamente, ahahah - Allora ci davano Alessandra Valeri Manera, grande Alessandra Valeri Maneri
Ci dava appunto le sinossi, facevamo dei briefing, nel senso
delle riunioni in cui ci spiegava la dinamica del cartone etc
A un certo punto hanno iniziato a darci i dvd dei cartoni animati
- Solo da un certo punto in poi?
- Hanno detto "Ma sì, ci possiamo fidare" - ahahaha
"Bene e visto che sei una ragazza ti devo trattare bene"
(Karim) - Mi piace che Bulma abbia la magia con scritto "Bulma" sul petto
perché così si ricorda chi è
- Bulma mi ricorda inevitalmente le duecentomila cosplayer fantastiche
che si vestono da Bulma e che formano questa schiera pazzesca
e menomale che ci sono perché io guardando il loro labiale quando cantano insieme a me
posso cantare correttamente i testi perché non mi ricordo     - Sono suggeritrici praticamente, le metti in prima fila
- Io guardo il loro labiale e mi ricordo i testi
- Giustamente 53 anni, siam lì ormai          - Eh, capisci?
"Ma non mi avevi detto che tuo nonno era morto?"
"Evviva, l'ho trovata! La sfera del drago"
- E qui è Goku che sta parlando con un'arancia del nonno
- Beh, devo dire che i nonni con i cartoni animati, ovviamente con i bambini,
c'è una schiera di pirati della ciurma, ci sono tantissimi ragazzi che ai cartoni animati abbinano anche il ricordo dei nonni
- Ovvio certo. Io purtroppo non ho avuto tanto quella fortuna lì perché sono morti quando io ero ancora piccolo e non li ho....
- ... vissuti?     - Vissuti esatto, a dovere
Però appunto, l'età in cui abbiamo visto questo in teoria è il periodo in cui noi stiamo di più con i nostri nonni
- (Giorgio) Si!   - (Karim) E quindi anche vedere questo rapporto tra Goku e il suo...
"Ho scoperto che si tratta di un oggetto fantastico"
- Un'arancia! (risate)
- Ahh, buongiorno!    - Fantastico questo è un personaggio fantastico!
- (Karim) Qui si vedeva già il drago nella prima puntata. Oh, guarda!   - (Giorgio) Si, fantastico!
- Ancora a 53 anni devo decidere se tatuarmi sul braccio destro, giuro...
è un disegno che ha fatto mio figlio, due draghi che si guardano uno più grande e uno più piccolo
- Bellissimo!       - Eh, però devo decidere, deve esserci qualcosa che mi con... convincimi tu scusa!
- Ma quale drago fare?       - No tutt'e due!
- A farlo??       - A farlo, si, dimmi "fallo" e io...
- Ma tu sei più giovanile di me, se tu ti facessi un tatuaggio faresti cadere le donne ai tuoi piedi...
- (Giorgio sarcastico) certo, si si...
- Poi non potresti approfittarne, però...      - Poi dovrei portarle al pronto soccorso (risate)
"Ah ho capito, conosco un buon mezzo di persuasione"
- (Karim) Attenzione!    - (Giorgio) Questa cosa qua mi ha sempre colpito
del cartone animato giapponese che ha veramente dei momenti abbastanza...       - (Karim) Si, si
- (Giorgio) Abbastanza spinti     - (Karim) Beh, per l'epoca e per un cartone animato per bambini direi che è abbastanza spinto
- Infatti prendi Lupin che ha delle cose... e questo mi ha sempre stupito abbastanza
- Anche perché Dragon Ball ha un target diverso di Lupin e far vedere queste cose qui...     - Assolutamente
"Ma se non sappiamo dove si trovano le altre sfere del drago come facciamo a trovarle?"
"Hmpf, sono molto carina ma non sono un'oca"
(Karim ride)
- Cioè, lei che si dice "Sono molto carina..."                      -"E non sono un'oca"
- Anche se prima gli ha fatto vedere le mutande per aver la sfera, però...
"Ma tu sei una maga, dimmelo sei forse una strega cattiva?"
- Lui che c'ha la coda dice a lei "ma tu sei una maga?"
- Questo qua è il tipo che era a Sanremo con Gabbani (risate)
Si e poi è diventat grande ed è andato a fare...     - Si, è lui, è lui, ha fatto carriera ha fatto a Sanremo
"Ah si, mi sembra che per farlo funzionare girasse questo coso"
"Si muove, si muove evviva, evviva, lo sapevo lo sapevo!"
- E lui impara subito e questo gliel'ho sempre invidiato, perché son caduto tre volte in moto
- E chissà quanti si ricordano che la prima scena d'azione di Dragon Ball è Goku in moto
che insegue Bulma catturata da uno pterodattilo
"Fai qualcosa!"
- "Fai qualcosa", ma poverino...
- Sta precipitando
- (Giorgio) Ha imparato ad andare in moto, ha preso la patente in cinque secondi, sta volando
- (Karim) Sta anche cercando di aiutarti quindi dai...
"Allora ti decidi o no a venire a salvarmi?"
- Sempre, la deve sempre salvare
"Questo non è che l'inizio del lungo e avventuroso viaggio intrapreso da Bulma e Goku alla ricerca delle sfere del drago"
"riusciranno a trovarle? Lo vedre...."
- "Lo vedre." Va bene (risate)
- Cioè la cosa che mi affascina di più...
In molti anime, perché succede nell'ambito di molte storie di anime, è che il disegnatore, il creatore
fa un mix, un mash up tra antico e futuro
- (Karim) Si, infatti nella stessa scena puoi vedere
Goku che cammina in mezzo ai dinosauri e poi Bulma che arriva con la macchina volante
- (Giorgio) E questa cosa qua mi ha sempre affascinato moltissimo.
Mentre guardavamo mi è venuto in mente anche l'altro cartone di Akira Toriyama per cui io e Max abbiam fatto la sigla
e l'ho cantata con Cristina D'Avena: Dottor Slump e Arale ed è una delle sigle che mi è piaciuta di più
Ho avuto la fortuna appunto di duettare con lei in tante sigle, quella sigla mi piace moltissimo
e mi piace tantissimo proprio la contaminazione di Goku in Arale e Arale nel mondo di Goku
Bella mi è piaciuta!
- Andata? A posto? Perfetto
Non ti ha assalito un'onda di ricordi incredibile?
- Un'onda ENERGETICA di ricordi!
- Potrei mettere questo come titolo del video, io te lo dico
- Beh, il ricordo principale, quello più importante è che io e Max non ci rendevamo tanto conto
che stavamo facendo una cosa molto grande
poi questa consapevolezza, come ti dicevo prima, si è proprio realizzata quando abbiamo iniziato a fare gli spettacoli
e a vedere tutti questi ragazzi che, veramente, sono...
all'inizio non riuscivo neanche a capire questa cosa qua. Dal vivo possono rivivere quei momenti in cui, appunto
sentivano la sigla e iniziano "Ah, figata bello!" e inizia il cartone, mi diverto, ho dei ricordi...
son seduto sul divano con mia nonna, con mio padre, con mia madre
- Beh certo, ovvio
- Ce ne siamo resi conto dopo. Anche un altro ricordo: da dove prendo, dove vado, a che cosa mi ispiro?
A me è sempre piaciuta la dance...
- Si nota! Ahaha
- A Max è venuto in mente: Dai...
- Dai, andiamo avanti, facciamo il "tunz tunz" mettiamo una cassa in quattro, con una melodia però assolutamente orecchiabile
perché Alessandra Valeri Manera ci ha sempre chiesto, come agli altri autori
melodie immediate, cioè che potessero essere memorabili
- Tu prima hai parlato di "tunz tunz" nelle tue canzoni, ma non tutte erano così
E mi hanno fatto notare che, per esempio, la canzoni di "Scarafaggi", "Scarafaggi - sca - sca"
Ha effettivamente tonalità ska!
(Giorgio) - Si, è ska!
- Allora abbiamo abbracciato anche generi: il rock, un rock particolare con Diabolik, Diabolik è stata sempre molto apprezzata
Gli Scarafaggi ska e poi il reggae, un sentore di reggae in alcune sigle
- Ed è molto bello perché queste cose le capisci soltanto da un'età in poi
prima è solo la sigla dei cartoni animati poi inizia a diventare, quando inizi a crescere da spettatore una vera e propria canzone
in cui riesci a sentire gli strumenti, il ritmo e il genere
- Certo, certo
- E infatti tutte le volte che facciamo il soundcheck io tutte le volte con i ragazzi accenno:
(Sigla di Dragon Ball versione reagge)
- Bellissimo!
Ho voglia di un cocktail! Adesso però sono riuscito ad immaginarti con i dreadlock
- C'ho un po' di dreadlock?
- Adesso si!
- Ohh! Hai visto?
- E però devo finire con una...
UH YEAH.
- Ah giustamente, sennò non è reggae
(Karim) - Allora lì ci sono alcune strofe nelle canzoni un po' particolari...
- Ma, le devo aprire tutte o...?
- Una per volta, e leggi quello che c'è scritto e di' quello che vuoi
- Quello che voglio...
- Sei sicuro?
Vuoi continuare a fare questo lavoro?
(Karim) - Ma ci becchiamo delle denunce?
- Noooo (risate)
( Karim) - Ecco "Ba ba ba bau"...
- Allora... ti devo svelare una cosa
Mentre stavamo componendo Beyblade io e Max c'era un cane fuori.... (risate fuori campo)
No scherzo, non è vero. Abbiamo sempre ritenuto importantissimo il suono delle parole
"Ba ba ba bau" non c'entra niente, però suonava bene
"spinning round and round" ovviamente perché girano in continuazione 'spinning'
Pensavo che fosse già all'epoca lo spinning, sai quello che fanno...
(Karim) - Ah, l'acquagym!
(Giorgio) - No, Clefable non te lo apro
(risate)
No, okay...
"Charizard, clafable, taurus, venasaur"
(Legge Clefable con la pronuncia corretta)
Non lo sapevi neanche tu però, eh!
(Karim) - Son andato a cercarlo...
- è stata proprio una roba, c'è venuto in mente di, invece di pronunciarlo in inglese Clefable
pronunciamolo come è scritto, così almeno... Mi sto arrampicando sugli specchi
(Karim) - Sì, tantissimo"
- Sul vetro della tua... e mi è venuto così!
Vediamo se riuscissi: (cantando) Charizard, Clafable, Taurus, Venasaur
Beh dai è venuto bene comunque
(Karim) - L'hai pronunciato comunque sbagliato
- Oh cinque anni di linguistico per buttarmi via come...
(Karim) - e poi?
- The magic to be free. Ehm, aspetta no...
(Karim) - Ecco, perché è lo stesso problema nostro
- In a world that wants really to be free
(Karim) - Oh, l'abbiamo scoperto finalmente!
- Fammelo dire, perché adesso sono emozionato allora faccio schifo
"In a world that wants really to be free", in un mondo che vuole veramente essere libero
(canta la strofa)
(Karim) - Ci abbiamo messo quei venti anni a capirla però...
- C'ho messo cinque anni di linguistico vuoi buttarli via così?
(Karim) - Ecco noi vorremmo capire, perché noi l'abbiamo capita quella frase lì, ma il senso...?
- Eh che non si può, come si dice non si può... ehm... (Karim ride)
- Allora, io l'ho capita! "Nobody can match this amazing catch" Nessuno può eguagliare questa fantastica presa, oppure questa fantastica cattura
(Karim) - Qui ce ne sono due, sono la stessa frase da due testi diversi su internet
(Giorgio) - Perché "fastest"? No, è "Burstin' through the clouds"
Cioè che esplode tra le nuvole.
Fantastico! E poi "fightin on the ground"
Cioè combatte sul terreno
(Giorgio) - To achieve your fame, per acquistare la tua "fame", per arrivare al tuo successo
(Karim) - Perché per noi era "Strizzi uei" tre volte
Perché non sapevamo assolutamente...
- Io all'inizio volevo "strizzi uei", poi non me l'hanno permesso (risate)
è stata una tortura questa cosa qua, cioè ragazzi vi voglio ricordare una cosa
"kamehameha nobody can match this amazing catch"
(risate)
(Karim fuori campo)
E questa è la storia di come ho conosciuto Giorgio Vanni
Io sono veramente onorato ed è stato magnifico poter collaborare con lui
Grazie mille e ci vediamo ad un prossimo episodio.
(Cantando)
"Chi sei Karim non lo sai però presto lo scoprirai e poi tu ti filmerai"